airling Harland of Norway leads a list
of major absentees at Qatar 2022 after
their countries didn't qualify for the
World Cup I wish I played the World Cup
of course
but that's reality now I don't do but
hopefully in the future one day I'll be
able to to play them
among the Mohamed Salah of Egypt Swedish
veterans Zlatan Ibrahimovic and the
entire Italian team that won Euro 2020.
but with 18 goals already for Manchester
City this season Hal and will for some
fans be the biggest missing name
but he won't be missed here this is
Howland a Swedish Coastal Province
trying to keep its tourism campaign on
track after being hijacked by algorithms
directing people to the blonde Striker
Harland instead of the Golden Sands of
Holland
more and more people are looking for new
places to go with the Google search or
other search engines and the use image
search
so if you're looking for Holland all you
see is a great football player and
that's of course a problem we want to
show great pictures of our place
Holland the Swedish County can take some
comfort that it's fairly famous for
football in its own right the biggest
Club helmstad produced former Arsenal
star Frederick youngberg and Holland
County provides the most players per
capita to the Swedish top League of any
in Sweden
but those stats might not be quite juicy
enough to take Holland out of Harlan's
Shadow online it's not only spelling but
pronunciation they have to contend with
airling Harland is written differently
in Norwegian to in English and is
actually pronounced Horland so
commentators in the rest of the world
calling Horland Harland is just adding
to the confusion
for Holland Holland or Holland being out
of the spotlight during the World Cup is
unlikely to stop him popping up in
searches for Holland given the
norwegian's fame it's probably not an
entirely unwelcome Association for the
swedes Paul Reese aldizera haland Sweden